lekha so catchy didn't want the bow mark  play here's Conley Conley cheaters  around that ties it with a floater Nets  can take a timeout  will they they will they just uses his  quickness to get right around on their  space on the inside didn't what he's  focused on not allowing to dump off by  hollis-jefferson  connelly tips around him and lays it in  and a great move by Connolly to be  honest I'm surprised that's not how he  finished off the first shot  Conley's jumper is smooth and Memphis  starts OT of the second variety with  four straight and a doe run if you go  back to the end of the first overtime  that's looking for a bucket here and  Russell keeps it tool in three-point  variety lead is four for Memphis Russell  another three Russell into the lane lays  it up I'm not sure how he got that to go  leave the P egg the sole  is back now at 26 he has the last eighth  for Brooklyn they lead by one no longer  its Connelly for Memphis